they came with sunflowers and
chrysanthemums and notes of condolence
and carried them down to the entrance of
the sandringham estate a place the royal
family knows well
the queen came here for christmas and
the prince and princess of wales own a
house on the estate
and when they arrive to greet
well-wishers well it may have felt like
coming home
they looked at the flowers now
enveloping the front gate
then spoke to dozens of people who
journeyed to north norfolk to see them
the mood was neighborly and prince
william was willing to share
through the world yesterday was
challenging memories
[Music]
you kind of think to yourself i've
prepared for this but i'm not that
prepared he said comparing the
procession of the late queen's coffin to
westminster hall
to his experience at the funeral of his
mother princess diana 25 years ago
it was a startling expression of
openness but it seemed in keeping with
this event for there were other moments
of warmth and emotion
when a schoolgirl called elizabeth
presented the princess of wales with a
toy kate came up with another plan
and i went with her to put the flowers
on the pool
do you remember what she said to you
she said
and very very humble and you could say
she was emotional
that um
and i just said you know sorry for your
loss
but he says everybody's loss
you know there's more than one way to
say goodbye to the queen and a lot of
people here have had a chance to speak
directly and offer their condolences to
the prince and princess of wales but it
didn't go according to plan for one
couple they said they were approached by
catherine princess of wales and they
became completely tongue-tied they
couldn't get anything out they're
mortified
but i think they'll be okay
the sandringham estate is much like
balmoral a place of peace and some
privacy for the royal family but its
famous chapel makes an annual appearance
queen elizabeth came here to worship on
christmas day
and it won't be the same without her
to not see the queen at three o'clock on
christmas day will just be
whatever for my whole life that's what
i've seen and we've always sat down at
three to do that so it'd be very strange
open and relatable prince william has
revealed something of himself at
sandringham as the royal family
commemorates the past and plans for the
future
john sparks sky news at sandringer